[BIRDS CHIRPING]
I love running without headphones on.
New York City always sounds different.
I don't get bored.
People having different conversations.
Excuse me.
Different people walking different dogs.
People that I see running and hear
the cadence of their footsteps.
Every so often, you come across a gutsy woman
like Melissa Blume.
Born legally blind, Mel started running with Achilles in 2015
and has since completed five New York City marathons.
Hi.
I'm going to give you a hug because we
should have another hug.
We definitely should.
Yay.
Hug it out.
I'm really bad about--
Freaking balance.
--stretching.
[LAUGHS]
Do a little stretch.
I'm doing my right leg first.
Oh, good Lord.
All right.
Oh.
I mean, you have the one arm out and very statuesque.
But you don't warm up or cool down?
Not really.
And you've run almost 10 marathons?
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
Basically, you're like, I'm a machine?
She's a total machine and won't admit it.
Is this where you normally run?
Yes.
And actually, we met in Central Park at an Achilles practice.
Step down.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Down one more.
Here we go.
Achilles International is a global organization
that pairs athletes with disabilities
with able-bodied guides.
Coming up, we've got a real dip.
Counting down.
5, 4, 3, 2, dip.
We met, I think, 2016.
Nice and smooth.
Keep your feet up.
While I was training, I saw Achilles shirts.
You could spot Achilles athletes in any crowd
with our bright neon yellow shirts.
I saw athletes with several different disabilities,
athletes tethered.
Line runners and you see athletes
with running blades and prosthetics.
And I thought, oh, I wonder what that's about.
So I researched online and applied.
Just keep your feet up on the down.
We'll cruise.
Excuse us.
Come by me.
Then follow me until we pass these people.
My biggest challenge when running
is my visual impairment.
So Brooke's there.
She's my eyes.
Careful.
It's rolling in here, a little divot.
OK.
I have an eye condition that's called aniridia
that reduces sharpness in my vision
and makes my eyes very sensitive to light.
I also have cataracts that make my vision blurry.
A mutual friend of mine told me about Achilles.
And ever since then, I've been coming almost every week.
[LAUGHS]
I met Mel, I think, my first day at Achilles.
We met and bonded over fashion that day,
and then we started running together.
It's hard to run on your own with a visual impairment.
Really, she's just been there for me.
Sorry.
Keep it right here.
I run with Mel so much, it's second nature and the way
that we work and communicate.
Plot foot here.
Uneven terrains--
With rocks and roots.
It just took more communication.
Root, rock, tree branch, ascending.
We're starting to climb.
So you narrate the whole time?
And she'll do it.
She goes.
Nice work, Mel.
You don't even look down.
You just go.
I like living on the edge.
[LAUGHS]
Has your family been able to come cheer you on?
They're definitely my biggest fans.
And I really don't know where I would be--
I don't know.
I really don't know, to be honest, what my situation would
be like without them.
Both of my parents are blind, and they found me.
When I was three, I was adopted from Korea.
They knew about my visual impairment.
They've just been the best example for me.
They taught me to really advocate for myself
and just let people know, it's not a bad thing.
It's like, if you need extra help,
just let them know about your visual impairment, and it's OK.
I could really just do anything, no limitations.
That's just the way they raised me.
No matter if it's going to be a good day or a bad day,
keep showing up for yourself.
That's awesome.
How about yourself?
How did you get into running?
So I got into running, really-- my dad ran.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think you can run here forever and not get tired of it.
I was like a kid running after my dad,
probably more accurately, than running with my dad.
When I got to college, one of my friends
was like, oh, you should try running.
And I remember having to go buy a pair of running shoes.
I had never been on a run.
And I ran 2 miles the first time.
And I was like, I ran 2 miles.
And one of my friends, who was on the Stanford tennis team,
was like, 2 miles?
And I was like, that was a big deal for me.
[LAUGHTER]
And then I just ran more and more and just never stopped.
I hear you're running the marathon.
Well, I mean, I'm planning on it, yeah, because, I mean,
the longest I've ever run is 11 miles.
You'll get there.
And all I want to do is finish.
My daughter's so enthusiastic.
And I feel, good Lord, such a responsibility to her now
to make her proud of me.
So I can't disappoint her.
That's what matters most to me.
It'll be great.
You're gutsy to her.
Brooke and I have run all distances together, from a 5K
to a marathon to a 50k.
Yeah.
Are you done?
Do you think you'll do something beyond 50K?
What's next?
A 50-miler or I'm thinking about doing maybe a 100-miler
at some point.
Completely nuts.
[LAUGHS]
We'll see?
We'll see.
TBD?
We'll think about it.
We're running New York City Marathon too.
All right.
Well, I'll probably be cheering you on as you both pass me.
I'll be cheering you on.
That's huge.
I'll be waving.
I'll be like, yay, I'll be back here, just trying to finish.
[LAUGHS]
You'll get there.
[CHEERING]
People give me all the credit.
However, Brooke shows up for me because she wants to and not
because she has to, and that seems pretty gutsy to me.